[Music]
good morning Janet Thursday November 8th
welcome back to my home I've been out of
town for a very long time and it is
really nice to be sitting in my basement
I love this facing so much yes that is
an innie gotcha poster yes that is a
cowboy Viva poster there's another
cowboy bebop opposed to right behind the
camera there's a very giant poster over
there down there at the mouth of the
realm of Narnia which we've been over
captain's guitar and that's my guitar
our party blowers if you're wondering
that one is d sharp I label them there's
my computer which I love which has a
mouse which I really really love while I
was on vacation they don't like forty
hours of work a week with the touchpad
he hate the touchpad now my finger is
extremely strong but he is also angry at
me John I just talked to you on the
phone and found out that you feel like
crap and I'm sorry to hear that to have
an ear infection that requires a
morphine shot I think probably shouldn't
happen to people however I do have
something that is definitely going to
make you feel better
Oh does it hurt when people talk loud I
don't know but I can't contain myself
now I have to find it where do they put
it huh I have something in a ziplock bag
that I'm very much looking forward to
showing you you have previously stated
that it was your lifelong ambition to
have a peep shaped like you and now you
do this is what nerdfighters can do they
can make dreams come true oh my god it's
you peep it's got a brotherhood 2.0
shirt on he's got a wedding ring he's
got your glasses very different from my
glasses he's got your hair and he's made
of marshmallow the John Green people was
created by cooking nerdfighter Jen Rudd
and I am amazed at its quality I don't
really want to eat you I'm not going to
I'm going to save you and maybe I should
ship you to you but if it's okay with
you I will eat you and I'll eat you
while discussing the political situation
in Chad maybe Chad Chad sound good to
you Chad is that interesting she also
made a bunch of little eco geek logo
once I've been eating them do you
remember when it is like months and
months and months ago three the prod to
me made me eat a lot of peeps and I was
like full peeps and they were it coming
out my eyeballs and I that did doesn't
it was funny
now I've had too much marshmallows and
I'm doing it again
but it's ego geek logos it's like I made
a vehicle geek I love it I love it I
love Cinnabon for like the scraps
leftover from the sides I'm gonna you
know thank you Ken
I'm enjoying them remarkably delicious
they taste exactly like marshmallows
except possibly a little bit better
they're awesome I am speechless and then
the sugar
I'm gonna go probably run around the
house a few times and then fall asleep
for about 12 hours John I hope if you
better I'll see you tomorrow
no scavenger hunt clue today because I
don't know what John was planning on
doing and now he's sick and this lack of
a clue is not some kind of clue and
disguise though I'm sure if I didn't say
that people would say that in my pants
it is what it is no clue today sorry